Hice una promesa de que a partir de ahora,
cada vez que una de mis hijas me pidiera que jugara
sin importar lo que hacía o dónde iba,
diría que sí, siempre.
Casi. No soy perfecta, pero me esfuerzo mucho por ponerlo en práctica.
Y tuvo un efecto mágico en mí,
mis hijos y nuestra familia.
Pero también tuvo un efecto secundario sorprendente
que comprendí completamente solo hace poco,
cuando entendí que decir sí y jugar con mis hijas
probablemente salvó mi carrera.
Tengo lo que muchos llamarían un trabajo ideal.
Soy escritora. Invento historias. Me pagan para inventar.
El trabajo ideal.
No.
Soy un titán.
Tengo un trabajo ideal.
Creo TV. Soy productor ejecutivo de series de TV.
Hago TV, muchísima TV.
De una manera u otra, esta temporada
soy responsable de la producción de unas 70 horas de programación.
Cuatro programas, 70 horas de TV...
(Aplausos)
Produzco 3 hasta 4 programas simultáneamente.
Cada serie crea cientos de nuevos puestos de trabajo.
El presupuesto para un episodio de serie de TV
puede variar entre USD 3 y 6 millones.
Digamos cinco.
Un nuevo episodio cada 9 días, por 4 series,
significa USD 20 millones por cada 9 días en la TV,
4 programas, 70 horas de TV,
3 series producidas al mismo tiempo, a veces 4,
son unos 16 episodios simultáneamente:
24 episodios de "Grey", 21 episodios de "Escándalo"
15 episodios de "Cómo defender a un asesino"
10 episodios de "La trampa", son unas 70 horas de TV,
es decir USD 350 millones por temporada.
En Estados Unidos, mis programas se transmiten los jueves por la noche.
En todo el mundo, se transmiten en 256 lugares, en 67 idiomas,
para un público de 30 millones de personas.
Mi cerebro es internacional
y 45 horas de estas 70 horas de TV son programas que yo misma he creado
y no solo producido, por lo que, por encima de todo lo demás,
necesito encontrar tiempo, momentos de tranquilidad y creatividad,
para reunir mis fans alrededor de una fogata y contarles mis historias.
Cuatro programas de TV, 70 horas,
3 series en producción simultánea, a veces 4,
salen a USD 350 millones por fogatas encendidas en todo el mundo.
¿Saben quién más está haciendo eso?
Nadie, por lo que, como he dicho, soy un titán.
Un trabajo ideal.
(Aplausos)
No digo esto para impresionarles.
Sino porque sé lo que piensan cuando oyen la palabra "escritor".
Lo digo para que todos Uds. que trabajan arduamente,
y gestionan una empresa o un país o un aula,
o una tienda o una casa,
me tomen en serio cuando hablo de trabajo,
para que entiendan que no me quedo todo el día delante del teclado soñando,
para que me oigan cuando digo
que entiendo que en un trabajo ideal no se trata de soñar.
Es todo trabajo, realidad, sangre y sudor, nada de lágrimas.
Yo trabajo mucho, arduamente, y me encanta.
Cuando estoy trabajando arduamente, y completamente inmersa en ello
no hay lugar para otras emociones.
Para mí, el trabajo siempre es como construir una nación de la nada.
Es como dirigir las tropas. Pintar un lienzo.
Es tocar cada nota alta. Es como correr un maratón.
Es ser Beyoncé.
Y es todas esas cosas al mismo tiempo.
Me encanta trabajar.
Es creativo, mecánico, agotador y estimulante
y divertido, inquietante, terapéutico y maternal
y cruel y sabio,
y lo que lo hace tan bueno es el zumbido.
Hay un cambio en mi cabeza cuando el trabajo se vuelve interesante.
Algo en el cerebro empieza a ronronear
y crece y crece y se parece a un camino despejado
del cual puedo disfrutar para siempre.
Y mucha gente, cuando trato de explicarles el zumbido,
cree que hablo de guiones,
que la escritura me hace feliz.
Y no me malinterpreten, es así.
Pero el zumbido...
No fue hasta que empecé a hacer TV,
a trabajar, trabajar y crear,
construir, crear y colaborar
que descubrí esto, este murmullo, este frenesí, este zumbido.
El zumbido es más que escribir.
El zumbido es acción y actividad. El zumbido es una droga.
El zumbido es música. El zumbido es la luz y el aire.
El zumbido es Dios que susurra en mi oído.
Y cuando oyes un zumbido de este calibre
no puedes más que aspirar a grandes cosas.
Es una sensación de aspirar a grandes cosas a cualquier precio.
Eso se llama el zumbido.
O, tal vez se le llama ser un adicto al trabajo.
(Risas)
Tal vez se llama genio.
Tal vez se llama ego.
Tal vez es solo miedo al fracaso.
No lo sé.
Solo sé que no me crearon para fracasar
y que simplemente me encanta el zumbido.
Solo sé que quiero decirles que soy un titán,
y que no quiero que haya duda sobre ello.
Pero es así: cuanto más éxito tengo,
más series, más episodios, y más obstáculos derribo,
más trabajo tengo que hacer.
Cuanto más malabares,
más ojos posados sobre mí, más me persiguen las historias,
mayores las expectativas.
Cuanto más trabajo para tener éxito,
más tengo que trabajar.
¿Y qué fue lo que dije sobre el trabajo?
Que me encanta trabajar, ¿verdad?
La nación que estoy construyendo, la maratón que estoy corriendo,
las tropas, el lienzo, la nota alta, el zumbido,
El zumbido, el zumbido.
Me gusta el zumbido. Me encanta el zumbido.
Necesito ese zumbido. Soy ese zumbido.
¿Soy algo más que este zumbido?
Y luego el zumbido se detuvo.
Demasiado trabajo, agotada,
exhausta, quemada.
El zumbido se detuvo.
Ahora, mis tres hijas son muy conscientes
de que su madre es un titán soltero y trabajador.
Harper dice a la gente:
"Mi madre no estará allí, pero puedes enviar un mensaje de texto a la niñera".
Y Emerson dice: "Cariño, quiero ir Shondalandia".
Son hijas de un titán.
Son cachorros de titán.
Tenían 12, 3 y un año cuando el zumbido se detuvo.
El zumbido del motor se apagó.
Dejé de disfrutar trabajando. No podía arrancar el motor.
El zumbido no iba a oírse,
no volvía.
Estaba haciendo lo mismo de siempre el mismo trabajo de titán,
15 horas al día, incluso los fines de semana,
sin remordimientos, sin rendirme,
un titán nunca duerme y nunca se da por vencido.
Con todo el corazón, visión clara, bla, bla, bla; lo que sea.
Pero no había zumbido.
Dentro de mí había silencio.
Cuatro programas de TV, 70 horas,
tres series en producción simultánea, a veces cuatro.
Era el titán perfecto.
El titán que te gustaría presentar a tu madre.
Todo era igual, solo que yo ya no lo disfrutaba.
Y era mi vida.
Era todo para mí.
Yo era el zumbido y el zumbido era yo.
Por lo tanto, ¿qué haces cuando la cosa que haces,
el trabajo que te gusta empieza a tener mal sabor?
Ya sé que habrá alguno por ahí pensando:
"¡Qué lástima, estúpida señora-escritora titán".
(Risas)
Pero ya saben, si uno trabaja,
si crea, si trabaja, si ama lo que hace...
sea maestro, banquero, madre, pintor, o Bill Gates,
si te gusta otra persona que te hace oír el zumbido,
si conoces el zumbido,
si sabes cómo se siente un zumbido, si has llegado hasta el zumbido,
cuando se detiene, ¿qué queda de ti?
¿Qué eres?
¿Qué soy yo?
¿Todavía soy un titán?
¿Si la canción de mi corazón deja de tocar, puedo sobrevivir en el silencio?
Y es entonces cuando mi hija camarera sureña me hizo la pregunta.
Estoy a punto de salir, llego tarde, y ella me dice:
"Mami, ¿quieres jugar?"
Estoy a punto de decir que no, y me doy cuenta de dos cosas.
Uno, que se supone que tengo que decir sí a todo,
y dos, que mi camarera sureña no me llamó "cariño".
Y no se dirige así a nadie.
¿Cuándo pasó eso?
Al ser un titán y estar de luto por mi zumbido, me lo acabo de perder
mientras que ella está cambiando delante de mis ojos.
¿Así que dice: "Mami, ¿quieres jugar?"
Y digo, "Sí".
No hay nada de especial en esto.
Jugamos, y sus hermanas también
y nos reímos mucho,
y leo con voz dramática el libro "Todos hacen caca".
No hay nada fuera de lo normal.
(Risas)
Y, sin embargo, es fuera de serie,
porque en mi dolor y en mi pánico,
en la ausencia de mi zumbido
no tengo nada más que hacer que prestar atención.
Me centro.
Quedo quieta.
La nación que estoy construyendo, la maratón que estoy corriendo,
el lienzo, la nota alta ya no existen.
No hay más que dedos pegajosos y besos pegajosos
y voces diminutas y lápices de colores
y esta canción que dice que hay de dejar
lo que sea que esa chica de Frozen dice que hay que dejar.
(Risas)
Es todo paz y tranquilidad.
En este lugar hay tan poco aire que apenas puedo respirar.
Apenas puedo creer que esté respirando.
Jugar es lo contrario de trabajar.
Y estoy feliz.
Algo en mí se relaja.
Una puerta se abre en mi cerebro
y se forma una ráfaga de energía.
Y no es instantánea, pero sucede, ocurre de verdad.
La siento.
Un zumbido se asoma.
No se oye a todo volumen, es apenas perceptible;
es discreto y tengo que permanecer muy quieta para oírlo, pero está ahí.
No es "el" zumbido, pero es un zumbido.
Y ahora me siento como si supiera un secreto mágico.
Bueno, no hay que dejarse llevar.
Es solo amor. Eso es todo lo que es.
No es magia. No hay un secreto. Es amor.
Solo algo que hemos olvidado.
El zumbido, el zumbido del trabajo, el zumbido de un titán,
es solo un sustituto.
Si tengo que preguntarles quién soy,
si tengo que decirles quién soy,
si me defino en términos de series y horas de TV
y cómo mi cerebro es fantástico a nivel mundial
es que he olvidado lo que es un zumbido de verdad.
El zumbido no es el poder y no depende del trabajo.
El zumbido depende de la alegría.
El verdadero zumbido depende del amor.
El zumbido es la energía que nace del entusiasmo por la vida.
El zumbido real es confianza y paz.
El zumbido verdadero ignora la mirada de la historia,
los malabares cotidianos, las expectativas, la presión.
El verdadero zumbido es muy particular y original.
El zumbido real es Dios que te susurra al oído,
pero quizá Dios susurraba las palabras equivocadas,
porque ¿qué tipo de Dios me dijo que yo era un titán?
Es solo amor.
A todos nos vendría bien un poco más amor,
mucho más amor.
Cada vez que mis hijos me pidan que juegue,
diré que sí.
Es una regla seria por una razón,
para darme el permiso,
para librarme de toda culpa de ser adicta al trabajo.
Es una ley, por lo que no tengo otra opción,
y no tengo opción
si quiero oír el zumbido.
Me gustaría que fuera fácil,
pero no se me da bien jugar.
No me gusta.
No me interesa hacerlo tanto como quiero hacer un trabajo.
Es muy humillante enfrentar la verdad:
No me gusta jugar.
Trabajo todo el tiempo porque me gusta trabajar.
Me gusta trabajar más de lo que me gusta estar en casa.
Aceptar ese hecho es increíblemente difícil
ya que ¿a qué clase de persona le gusta más trabajar que estar en casa?
Bueno, a mí.
Es decir, seamos honestos, me llamo a mí misma un titán.
Tengo problemas, está claro.
(Risas)
Y uno de ellos es que no sé relajarme.
Corremos por el jardín de aquí para allá, de arriba abajo.
Tenemos fiestas de baile de 30 segundos.
Cantamos canciones de series. Jugamos con la pelota.
Hago pompas de jabón y ellas las rompen.
Y me siento rígida y rara y confusa la mayor parte del tiempo.
Siempre anhelo mi teléfono.
Pero está bien.
Mis pequeños humanos me muestran cómo vivir
y el zumbido del universo me llena.
Juego y juego hasta que empiezo a preguntarme
por qué dejamos de jugar en primer lugar.
Uds. pueden hacerlo también,
decir que sí cada vez que sus hijos les piden jugar.
¿Tal vez están pensando que soy una tonta?
Tienen razón, pero aun así, pueden hacer esto.
Tienen tiempo.
¿Saben por qué? Porque no son ni Rihanna ni un Muppet.
Sus hijos no piensan que son tan interesantes.
(Risas)
Solo hacen falta 15 minutos.
Mis hijas de 2 y 4 años solo quieren jugar conmigo
unos 15 minutos más o menos
antes de decidirse por cualquier otra cosa.
Son unos 15 minutos fantásticos, pero son 15 minutos.
Y si no soy una mariquita o un caramelo, después de 15 minutos soy invisible.
(Risas)
En cuanto a mi hija de 13 años,
si pudiera hacerle hablar conmigo 15 minutos, sería la Mamá del Año.
(Risas)
15 minutos es todo lo que hace falta.
Puedo sacar 15 minutos sin interrupciones incluso en mi peor día.
Sin interrupciones es la clave.
No hay teléfono móvil, no hay ropa para lavar, no hay nada más.
Están muy ocupados. Hay que preparar la cena.
Hay que obligarlos a bañarse. Pero se puede sacar 15 minutos.
Mis hijas me hacen feliz, son mi mundo.
Pero no tiene por qué ser sus hijos,
lo que alimenta su zumbido,
o el lugar donde la vida parece mejor.
No se trata de jugar con sus hijos,
Se trata de la alegría.
Se trata de jugar en general.
Tómense 15 minutos.
Descubran lo que les hace sentirse bien.
Averígüenlo y jueguen con ello.
No soy perfecta.
De hecho, fracaso y triunfo por igual,
sea que se trate de ver a los amigos, leer libros, mirar al vacío.
"¿Quieres jugar?" Se está convirtiendo en sinónimo de tomar un descanso,
de una manera que dejé de hacerlo
cuando empecé con mi primer programa de TV,
en el momento en que me convertí en aprendiz de titán,
justo en el momento que empecé a competir conmigo misma.
¿15 minutos?
¿Por qué sería malo concederme 15 minutos a mi misma?
No lo sería en absoluto.
El mismo hecho de no trabajar hizo posible el regreso del zumbido
como si el motor del zumbido solo pudiera repostar mientras yo descansara.
Trabar sin jugar no funciona.
Me costó un poco, pero al cabo de unos meses,
un día las compuertas se abrieron
y hubo una recarga y me encuentro de pie en mi oficina
llena de una melodía desconocida, llena de ritmo por dentro y alrededor
y de un torbellino de ideas,
y el camino hacía el zumbido está de nuevo despejado
y puedo disfrutarlo de nuevo, puedo disfrutar trabajando de nuevo.
Ahora me gusta el zumbido,
pero no lo amo y tampoco lo necesito.
No soy ese zumbido.
Ese zumbido no soy yo, ya no.
Soy las pompas de jabón, los dedos pegajosos y las cenas con amigos.
Soy ese zumbido.
El zumbido de la vida.
El zumbido del amor.
El zumbido del trabajo sigue siendo parte de mí, solo que ya no lo es todo
y estoy muy agradecida.
Y no me importa una mierda ser un titán,
porque nunca he visto una vez un titán jugar a "Capturar la bandera".
Dije que sí a menos trabajo y más juego,
y de alguna manera, todavía tengo el control.
Mi cerebro sigue siendo global. Mis fogatas están todavía ardiendo.
Cuanto más juego, más feliz soy, y más felices son mis hijas.
Cuanto más juego, más me siento una buena madre.
Cuanto más juego, más libre se vuelve mi mente.
Cuanto más juego, mejor trabajo.
Cuanto más juego, más siento el zumbido,
la nación que estoy construyendo, la maratón que estoy corriendo,
las tropas, el lienzo, la nota alta, el zumbido, el zumbido,
el otro zumbido, el verdadero,
el zumbido de la vida.
Cuanto más siento el zumbido,
más extraña, titubeante, torpe, renacida,
viva, nada de titán y más cerca de mí me siento.
Cuanto más siento el zumbido, más sé quién soy.
Soy escritora, invento cosas, imagino.
Es parte del trabajo, es vivir el sueño.
Es lo bonito del trabajo,
porque un trabajo de ensueño debe tener un poco de fantasía.
Dije que sí a menos trabajo y a más juego.
Absténgase los titanes.
¿Quieren jugar?
Gracias.
(Aplausos)